we have to bring you the latest on
Florida's covid-19 crisis the state now
has more than 12 thousand hospital
patients with a coronavirus this is the
highest number of the pandemic the
schools are about to open there and the
governor says that new coveted
requirements are out of the question
Manuel boorkus is outside a Memorial
Health Care System hospital that's in
Miramar which is located northwest of
Miami Manuel good morning to you
good morning Gail as the CEO of this
Hospital chain told us they are simply
trying to weather the storm right now
but come Monday they will have to
suspend all elective procedures for now
to accommodate the surge of covid-19
patients more than 90 percent of them
are unvaccinated
[Music]
inside Memorial Healthcare System in
Broward County ICU beds are once again
filling up fast it has gone up 400
percent in the last six weeks Aurelio
Fernandez is the president and CEO of
Memorial which recently added 266 extra
beds to keep up with demand we have
converted Conference Centers auditoriums
cafeterias to get the search and these
are clean patients we don't put covert
patients in this overflow areas but
these overflow areas for patients who
are not coveted positive have to be
built because of the ones who are that
is correct that surge includes children
as of yesterday 135 children under 18 in
Florida are hospitalized with covid the
highest it's ever been but you aren't
going to help at least get out of the
way on Tuesday President Biden called
out hot spot Governors including
Florida's Rhonda Santas for failing to
implement restrictions including Mass
mandates in schools that is something
the governor has no intention of doing
he thinks that should be a decision for
the government well I can tell you in
Florida the parents are going to be the
ones in charge of that position
DeSantis argued Biden's immigration
policies are responsible for the surge
claiming without any evidence that
undocumented immigrants are causing the
virus to spread why don't you get this
border secure and until you do that I
don't want to hear a blip about covid
from you thank you the rise of covetous
Florida is because of the Delta variant
and its infectiousness and secondarily
because of permissive Behavior cbsnews
medical contributor Dr David agus says
covet cases are surging in Florida for
other reasons with low vaccination rates
and going out without masks and in large
groups you're going to get significant
spread of the virus period and just last
week DeSantis signed an executive order
that would pull funding from districts
that require masks the minimum we could
do to protect all of the people who
decided to get back vaccinated or not is
to put our mask on even if we vaccinated
John Moreno Escobar who is running for
the Broward County school board and
whose son Luca will begin first grade
this year believes it's up to parents to
convince those who are hesitant how
would you try to convince them that the
masks are a good thing in the schools we
are protecting others by putting the
mask on putting a mask is protecting the
life of someone else and life is sacred
and we should protect it all as a
community
another challenge facing hospitals right
now isn't necessarily capacity but
Staffing shortages according to the
Florida Hospital Association 60 percent
of hospitals in the state could face a
critical Staffing shortage within the
next week Anthony Manuela horkas thanks
Manny